vamos a hacer un repaso de la línea de
presupuesto luego vamos a combinar eso
con las ideas que vimos en el vídeo
pasado de las curvas de indiferencia y
con esto vamos a poder encontrar un
punto óptimo para los bienes que
queremos comprar entonces supongamos que
tenemos un ingreso mensual de 200 pesos
de 200 pesos que el precio del chocolate
está en 10 pesos la barra le voy a poner
10 pesos la barra barra y que el precio
de la fruta está en 20 pesos el kilo 20
pesos el kilo entonces lo primero que
vamos a hacer es graficar nuestra línea
de presupuesto aquí tenemos el eje
vertical acá tenemos el eje horizontal
de este lado tenemos la cantidad de
chocolate que le mandamos y acá tenemos
la cantidad de fruta que está aquí es en
barras barras
y esto de acá es en kilos kilos y
supongamos que más o menos por aquí
están 20 barras por aquí están 10 barras
15 5 por acá están 20 kilos lo voy a
poner un poco más a la derecha por acá
están 20 kilos por acá están 10 kilos
aquí están 5 y 15 ok entonces bueno en
hace dos vídeos vimos cómo graficar la
línea de presupuesto y lo que hacíamos
era despejar en general unas variables y
luego íbamos interpretando los términos
ahorita lo voy a hacer de otra manera
para que veas que con los numeritos es
un poco más sencillo básicamente si
gastamos todo nuestro dinero en
chocolates podemos comprar 20 barras y
no podemos comprar nada de fruta
entonces tenemos el punto 0 20 pero
ahora si compramos todo en kilos de
fruta podemos comprar 10 kilos de fruta
y es kilos de fruta y nada de chocolate
entonces estos dos puntos de acá son
puntos en la línea de presupuesto y como
es una línea los podemos unir
podemos unir
y eso ya no es lo que quería los podemos
unir y eso de ahí es nuestra línea de
presupuesto vale entonces de la línea de
presupuesto y además tenía una ecuación
déjame escribirlo por aquí en algún
lugar teníamos que 200 era igual a 10
por la cantidad de chocolate más 20 por
la cantidad de fruta esto era porque nos
gastábamos todo y de aquí podríamos
despejar esta variable que queríamos que
fuera la variable independiente entonces
restando menos 20 qf de ambos lados
obtenemos que 220 cv efe es igual a 10 q
se me excusé y ahora dividiendo a ambos
lados de la ecuación entre 10 y poniendo
primero la q c tenemos que cursen es
igual a 20 menos 2 veces q efe esto de
aquí era la ecuación muy bien entonces
ese es el repaso de la línea de
presupuesto ahora vamos a ver qué sucede
con las curvas de indiferencia
supongamos que tenemos por aquí un punto
saber qué punto podría estar sobre esta
línea más o menos el 18 1
si pedimos 18 barras de chocolate esos
son 180 pesos y luego un kilo de frutas
serían 20 pesos más son los 200 entonces
aquí tenemos 18 barras de un kilo es un
punto sobre esta línea de presupuesto y
lo que dijimos es que había una cierta
curva que nos daba opciones que nos
daban igual que esta opción es decir que
las preferíamos igual que esta opción
que nos eran indiferentes entonces lo
que voy a hacer ahorita es graficar esa
curva vamos a ponerle que más o menos
viene así tiene que pasar por este punto
entonces más o menos viene como así y
luego se va haciendo como medio chueca
algo este estilo
y luego pasa por otro punto de por acá
vale más o menos así bueno eso de ahí es
la curva de indiferencia de estos y en
la curva de indiferencia de este punto
de acá es decir cualquier opción sobre
este punto sobre esta curva nos da lo
mismo por ejemplo está esta opción de
acá que sería más o menos como que como
9 kilos de fruta vamos a ponerle que son
aquí 9 kilos de fruta total y si son 9
kilos de fruta ya gastamos 180 entonces
serían 2 barras de chocolate para que
completemos los 200 este punto está
sobre esa misma curva de indiferencia
entonces nos da lo mismo tener un kilo
de fruta que 18 barras de chocolate va a
tener 9 kilos de fruta que dos barras
que dos barras de chocolate ok pero mi
pregunta es la siguiente este punto o
este punto serán óptimos
estaremos maximizando la utilidad pues
yo digo que no
o sea recordemos cómo funcionaba esto de
las curvas de indiferencia por arriba de
la curva de indiferencia teníamos
opciones que preferíamos más por abajo
opciones que preferíamos menos y en
curva de indiferencia a las opciones que
nos daban igual pero lo importante es
que acá arriba aquí arriba de la curva
de indiferencia le voy a poner aquí que
es la de indiferencia
diligencia
arriba de esta curva todavía tenemos
puntos sobre nuestra línea de
presupuesto es decir son puntos que si
podemos pagar que si podemos comprar con
lo que ganamos y que los preferimos
entonces para arriba laca para arriba
son preferidos preferidos y por tanto
nos convendría más tener por ejemplo
esta cantidad de a cada verdad porque
tenemos este tenemos un punto arriba de
la curva de indiferencia lo preferimos
más entonces éste lo preferimos lo mismo
que éste pero éste lo preferimos menos
que este de acá bueno entonces no estos
puntos de acá no maximizan la utilidad
total como le podemos hacer para que si
se maximice a pues lo que vamos a hacer
es ir moviendo esta curva de
indiferencia o bueno ir agarrando varias
curvas de indiferencia hasta que una se
vuelva tangente vale entonces va a haber
una curva de indiferencia quien nada más
va a pasar por uno de los puntos vamos a
ponerle algo así más o menos viene
a ver la voy a dibujar un poco mejor más
o menos viene por arriba luego toca en
este punto de acá y luego se separa
entonces esta de acá es otra curva de
indiferencia de nuevo todos los puntos
aquí son preferidos pero ahora yo digo
que este punto de acá ya es el óptimo
óptimo
porque pues mira supongamos que tomamos
cualquiera otra de las opciones sobre la
línea de presupuesto otra de las
opciones que podemos pagar entonces
cualquiera de estas opciones ya quedó
abajo de esta curva ya quedó abajo de
esta curva de preferencia entonces
digamos esta opción la preferimos menos
que esta de acá pero es para preferimos
igual que ésta entonces pues ésta la
preferimos mejor que ésta bueno más que
esta de acá y por tanto este acá es el
óptimo le gana a cualquiera de los de
esta línea muy bien entonces ya tenemos
una forma de encontrar el precio óptimo
tomamos todas las líneas todas las
curvas de indiferencia y nada más nos
fijamos cuál de ellas es tangente a
nuestra línea de presupuesto cuál tiene
la misma pendiente que la línea de
presupuesto en el punto de tangencia nos
está súper bien bueno ya sabiendo esto
quiero hacer una última observación
quiero ver qué sucede si cambiamos el
precio de la fruta supongamos que ahora
en vez de comprar 20 pesos por kilo
cuesta 10 pesos por kilo
entonces ahora va a costar 10 pesos cada
kilo mi pregunta es cómo se va a
modificar nuestro modelo y
específicamente cómo se va a modificar
la cantidad de fruta en el punto óptimo
bueno pues si cambiamos nuestro precio y
ahora está a 10 pesos por kilo una vez
más de este punto de acá está en la
línea de presupuesto podemos comprar 20
barras de chocolate pero también este
punto de acá va a estar en la línea de
presupuesto porque ahora podemos comprar
20 kilos de fruta de este modo nuestra
nueva línea de presupuesto sería esta
línea verde que acabo de pintar y ahora
qué sucede con pues con con estas curvas
de preferencia cuál sería la que están
gente pues las vamos moviendo y moviendo
y ahora más o menos por aquí más o menos
por aquí vamos a tener la nueva curva de
preferencia la voy a poner con este
color rosa mexicano entonces perdón aquí
tenemos el nuevo óptimo el punto de
tangencia entonces esta es la curva de
preferencia que hace más o menos esto es
tangente en este nuevo óptimo y qué
sucede con la cantidad de fruta que
demandamos
óptimo bueno pues vamos a ver este punto
de acá es el 10 10 entonces ahora
demandamos 10 kilos de fruta este óptimo
de mejor a una tabla vale para para que
lo veamos más claramente entonces aquí
voy a poner el precio de la fruta y aquí
la cantidad de la fruta en el óptimo y
lo voy a poner aquí óptimo o bien ok
entonces cuando el precio de la fruta
era 20 pesos por kilo voy a poner así
cuánta cantidad de fruta demandábamos
pues teníamos este punto de por acá que
es como 10 barras de chocolate entonces
para que juntemos 200 tienen que ser 5
kilos de fruta entonces aquí es 5 kilos
de fruta era lo que demandábamos pero
ahora que modificamos el precio de la
fruta a 10 pesos en este nuevo punto
óptimo estamos demandando 10 kilos de
fruta 10 kilos de fruta entonces qué
sucede es la misma idea que hemos estado
platicando acerca de cómo el precio
modifica la cantidad o sea de cómo se ve
la curva de demanda de nuevo cuando el
precio baja la cantidad aumenta y en
realidad si te das cuenta son las mismas
ideas pero nada más que están vistas
pues desde desde puntos de vista
distintos ahora tenemos un ángulo más
para entender por qué bajar el precio
aumenta la cantidad entonces ya con esto
nada más para terminar déjame
dibujar más o menos cómo quedaría
nuestra nuestra curva de demanda para la
fruta entonces aquí tenemos el precio de
la fruta y aquí la cantidad demandada de
fruta por aquí está 5 por aquí está 10
por aquí está uno y por aquí está 2
bueno 10 y 20 sale entonces aquí 5 10 10
2010 20 5 10
así cuando el precio de la fruta era de
20 se demandaban 5 cuando el precio de
la fruta es 10 se demandaban 10 y
entonces nuestra curva de demanda se
vería más o menos así
más o menos así
claro sí sí puedes justificar que es
lineal se vería como una línea recta
pero si no para determinar todos estos
precios intermedios bastaría con ir
moviendo el precio de la fruta poco a
poco para ver cómo se mueve la curva de
indiferencia poco a poco cómo se va
moviendo la tangente y con esto cómo se
mueve la cantidad de fruta